so US income inequality has hit the
highest level in 50 years we have just
learned and this is measured using
something called the Guinea index GI and
I let's talk about how the metric works
this is a measure of distribution of
income or wealth you can have an income
distribution measured with Guinea or
wealth distribution and it's across
income percentiles so it goes from 0 to
1 0 would be there is perfect equality
if everyone has the same income the
Guinea coefficient is 0 if everyone has
the same wealth the Guinea coefficient
is 0 1 would be perfect
inequality meaning if it you have a
country and one person has all the
income or all the wealth the Guinea
coefficients for income and wealth
respectively it would be 1 and you can
track it over time so in the United
States in 2017 it was zero point four
eight two and it went up in 2018 to zero
point four eight five it's an increase
of about half a percent this is a very
big calculation so it moves really
really slowly and then you can break it
down in more detail if you want you
could look at let's look at a change in
the inequality by gender or look at it
by the states people live in blue states
versus red states or you could look at
it by race or by age or whatever you
want wealth inequality went up in quite
a few heartland states which is
interesting because Donald Trump's trade
policy is potentially to blame they're
actually impacting inequality both
income and wealth in some of those
heartland states states on the East
Coast and the West Coast still have
higher inequality overall and that's
really not surprising since you have
more wealthy people on the coasts and
the most equal states interestingly
enough our Utah Alaska and the Dakotas
and maybe Iowa as well is on that list
and the right loves to look at that and
say look you've got all these liberals
who talk about equality and they say
they want equality but it's the red
states that actually have the most
equality and of course this is one of
those very low-energy interpretations
it's not a very high thinking
interpretation because the reason that a
lot of red states have low inequality is
that you just have way more people that
are not doing well and the truth is that
the degree of inequality matters there's
lots of externalities as well crime and
others but the reason for inequality is
also really important so if you want to
get an understanding of this if you want
to understand inequality number one
there's a lot of good books that I could
recommend that you should read but when
you're looking at something like the
Guinea coefficient you need to often
look qualitatively and if I'm to pick my
battles I have way less of a problem
with an entrepreneur who becomes wealthy
by creating something compared to
someone who inherits a ton of money and
then uses the money to buy influence and
to influence legislation to allow them
to get even wealthier now I want to be
clear we can argue all inequality is a
problem whether it's inherited or
whether it's the new rich of
entrepreneurship and the tech world but
when you break it down there are
different categories and it's important
that on the Left if we want to fight
against inequality we should understand
the sources of it and make sure that
we're dealing with the most serious
problems first now that being said we
have a system that encourages even the
entrepreneurs who become wealthy through
the business they've created to then get
into the influence-peddling
and to become one of the people that is
indistinguishable from those who have
just inherited money and used that money
to peddle influence and to change
legislation for their benefit and then
of course you also have entrepreneurs
who are getting wealthy thanks to the
tax sheltering laws and the other stuff
that the legacy influence peddlers were
able to get past so it's not a clean cut
the way I might be suggesting but the
point is we should be able to look at
this issue more qualitatively and really
determine what is most important
be addressing right away but the reality
is that if this continues to go in the
same direction of growing inequality
it's going to cause more social unrest
it's going to cause more crime it's
ultimately going to precipitate an
increasingly unsustainable system now
the solution to the problem is different
depending on your political ideology you
might have someone who is an actual
socialist I'm not talking about someone
who wants you know government health
care but you might have an actual
socialist who says the only solution is
to totally socialize the means of
production socialized property and
that's the way that we're going to fix
this problem Social Democrats would have
a different point of view which is some
degree of inequality is okay but what we
want to do is put some limits at the top
and use those to raise the floor so that
we are constricting inequality to a more
narrow band such that people aren't
getting left behind such that the riches
that come to some the few from the
system that we have are by statute by
law being reinvested to better
circumstances for everybody that would
be a socially democratic approach and
that's really at the heart of a lot of
the debate that is happening within the
left right now certainly the right has a
completely different point of view with
so-called free markets and all of the
other things that they say are really
great which have completely failed us
over the last hundred and fifty years in
this country but the data once again
income inequality increasing in the
United States from 2017 to 2018